brought to you by PlayStation Store
access to the ultimate and games and
entertainment hello and welcome back to
the lobby i'm your host Daniel Dwyer
joined as ever by mr. Christopher waters
and today we are very happy to be joined
by a man who is more names on boxes than
both Tom Clancy and even american mcgee
justice admire hello sir great to be
here thank you so much you're in time
for for GDC we're gonna roll in the back
in time here today on the lobby and I'm
guessing this isn't your first game
developers conference I've been to a
number game developer come yeah actually
back to the old days when I think there
maybe 50 of us so things have come a
long way was that just in somebody's
like backyard it was in san jose in a
hotel i remember their free cookies like
after every afternoon there'd be free
cookies i hope they kept that tradition
but that was that was really the reason
we came what's your main impetus to be
here at the moment because the GDC like
we see it from the press side like
you've come here today and they've done
a demo of starships and you know we see
various aspects of it but there's so
much actually happening at GDC between
business and talks what's your main
impetus to be here we're here primarily
to talk about starships our new game
which coming out soon play it kind of
give people a little more insight into
it we've been able to do a few live
streams to kind of cover the basics but
today we're talking about some of the
more detailed aspects about the strategy
the story behind it things like that
Chris you've covered a bunch of since
games between the aldi beyond Earth of
last year and starships as well now you
hosted the pacsafe panel as well oh yeah
add that the guys put on and today we're
you with the demo will be live on the
side for anyone's watch as a game spot
and now playing I've stopped just well
what is your feel of starships said you
had a bit more time with it uh this demo
was actually interesting because Sid
totally got like I kicked on one of the
missions great yeah like that I was
watching an invite but you know like so
many you know times when you're you're
showing off a game that's meant to be
complex and have this sort of difficulty
ceilings you don't want to you you want
to see the systems and show that stuff
off but you know in our past coverage it
sort of has been that that overview but
this definitely like like seeing sort of
where you're going to run into those
strategic difficulties that then force
you to be more
creative that then force you to make two
maybe specialize in one way to maybe
take it to like really lean into a
specific strategy that's sort of this
stage when demos reached that is always
to me a little bit more engaging so you
get to like see a little bit more than
beating heart of the game and what's it
like been working on it obviously it's
it's not the sort of the grand should
like insane amount of different
mechanisms like the civilizations games
its bit more refined the project what's
a like been working on starships it's
been a it's been a lot of fun but can I
say I did not get my butt kicked it was
incredible ai ai ai ai ai you know I
have to say the AI was awesome on that
particular me that's true so you've been
kicked your old but it'll run that yeah
exactly exactly but it's been a lot of
fun I mean starships that the whole
science fiction genre has been something
I haven't worked on yet but has always
been part of my kind of my childhood
something I always wanted to try and to
be able to do it in conjunction with
this cool story from beyond Earth when
you humanity going into the future and
and traveling throughout the galaxy
being able to use a new engine that we
developed for this that really doesn't
really need special effects in terms of
the way weapons look the way cities will
be lighted on the dark side of the
planet and then kind of turn to darker
cities and there's some cool special
effects that that really kind of think
bring out the science fiction nature I
know the artists were just slathering
you know when you said or gonna do a
science fiction candidate oh cool you
know I think that's the dream of artists
and they were able to kind of really do
some cool stuff so it was a very fun
project to work on will Miller and David
McDonough where the the leads on beyond
Earth and it's interesting say like you
haven't really had hands-on on a sort of
a science-fiction game yourself how does
that work cuz obviously a games with
your with your name on it and obviously
like for access being your baby
essentially like what is your
involvement in all of the games that
have the sid meier name on different
levels of involvement starships is a
game that I designed in programmed a lot
of the AI and there are rules in a game
like beyond Earth based on the
civilization system but the will and
Dave where the designers we turn them
loose and basically you can't kind of
you know a partly design you've got to
kind of turn your baby over to somebody
else is them really express themselves
and that's what they did with beyond
Earth
one what was that process like you're
handing it over to two incredibly
talented lovely guys we've had them on
the show before and incredibly talented
but quite young as well I was actually
surprised by it because it seems like
quite a complex sort of game to have to
make so what was it like working with
with them it it was it was great
civilization seems to kind of grab
certain people you know even though
they're young they they probably spend a
good part of their lives growing up with
civilization and have an insight into
kind of what makes it work that allowed
them to build on that and create yonder
hmm what do you think it is about
strategy games that they're so enduring
because there's so many genres Chris we
see like common go over the years lots
of them evolve some of them just plain
disappear from sight strategy games I
feel like like one of the first games I
ever played granted it was real time but
like dune on the old pc like strategy
seems to have just like the idea of like
isometrically working on things it's
largely similar to what it was like in
now in 2015 as it was when I was growing
up what do you think about it that was
that it's so enduring I mean I think
that these kind of games like what so
what do you want from a from a game
experience do you want there's that
there's a puzzle game there's a puzzling
aspect to a strategy but it's not just
you know where does this piece go how do
I get these things to match it's a
grander sort of longer form thing and so
the for me a game like sieve I get that
kind of strategy thing is absorbing and
it allows me to to take on the challenge
to take on a problem and to solve a
problem in a creative way and you know
depending on your job or where you work
or whatever you can get some of that in
your life but you know rarely can it can
the sort of parameters be so imagination
inspiring can the can they be tweaked
just so so that you have so that you
know the problems i encounter are
different every time I play civ but
there's still a mind behind it that is
set of systems that is going to crew
that's going to be very generative for
those kind of problems and be in a way
evergreen because of the sheer variety
of ways that those systems can
intertwine I think those intertwining
systems is is really the magic yes as
much change in terms of designing
strategy games because that they always
felt like a sort of an extension of
chess almost in a way but they've
extended far beyond that now
at 2015 the irony is when we when we
first created the original civilization
strategy was actually a dirty word as
far as computer games you know they were
associated with boring and slow moving
and and we actually wanted to use hexes
in the original soon but it was like no
you know people that will relate to like
war games which is only you know
hardcore geeks play Avery so we made you
know we use squares finally recently
it's become safe to use texas again but
civ kind of made the world safe for
strategy you know india of computer
games and and you know those core ideas
that that were introduced there seemed
to have this longevity that that's been
amazing you know the kind of one more
turn aspect the the ability to kind of
project to you with your imagination to
what's going to happen next i mean
that's the magic of turn bases that you
have the time to imagine what's going to
happen if i do this what's going to
happen or I do that and it kind of
created almost this idea that I've got
to play that turn and play that turn and
and see what what I imagined is actually
going to happen that's exactly thats
gonna come true so there's more in
tension in your move because you're
you're thinking about what's going to
happen but also it's almost like there
are different realities that are
happening much like in life when you
decide to you know go somewhere to live
or work and you could have chosen B or C
and then your imagination sort of it's
almost like when you're playing strategy
games you're playing thousands of games
but you've only gone down one sort of
roof so you gotta play again yeah I that
other family yeah and you've obviously
been creating strategy games for many
years now what is it about starships or
anything like new that you've done in
this thing you didn't you weren't able
to do maybe with civilization with the
sort of expectancy that there is with
that with a sort of an audience that
already exists yeah there's some new
systems the the starship customizing
system gives you so many possibilities
there's a neat crew fatigue system that
kind of allows gives you this
interesting risk reward in terms of how
long you want to push your crew on the
mission before you give them some shore
leave the the variety of missions i
think is one of the things i'm very
proud of that that you can play mission
after mission after mission and they'll
each be different and that's really what
keeps you going for keeps the game
really fresh
even though you can play for hours and
hours and hours you've got quite a like
a murderer's row of a design talent now
for access as well between will and Dave
and the excom team as well working on
great sake yeah Jake Salomon what what's
what's left what's next for four axes in
2015 once when starships is out there
well we're working on some cool new
stuff I can't quite talk about it yet
but I appreciate that we do have some
great designers at four axis takes the
load of me and I get to play some great
games so it's wonderful when it starts
out and the on wat systems were waking
people play starships is out on March
twelfth be available on a PC steam
Macintosh and on ipad excellent so it's
a over a week away for us but by the
time this goes out it'll be mere days
away yeah damn you future me thank you
so much for coming on just enjoy the
rest of GDC you're going to pax it all
not this year okay so by the time this
goes out you won't have been snowed in
to the Arctic tundra of bossa nova so at
least it is that I will be back in a
second with more la vie
you